[Music]
and night of the museum news I know this
one
what is it then say it say it the Louvre
you gotta stop reading news article my
bed oh I know about this one to them I
like you and events are surprised I
never read the news or lots of news or
even care about the news we were
actually I want that on sure I don't
care or read or whatever happen the news
I don't know so your only news source is
this that's not there's more important
[ __ ] going on in my life than the day I
agree with that but I think the monkey
that got stuck in a tree
if you want the news like a credible
news source I'd be worried for you Jacob
where do you go no middle-aged Facebook
moms are the best news sources yeah
exactly you know how many things I have
shoved up my vagina to make sure the
toxins go away
Groucho pearls dude I don't know what
the toxic is a huge word on Twitter
right now
toxic everyone says everyone's toxic now
I used to say they should have a joke
now I can't use that a joke anymore
I know he's like you're toxic I'm toxic
yeah the speeding Spears was toxic it's
like this person's toxic video dude she
was on in every video until 2007 exactly
yeah she lost her hair submitted by a
Cali boy
flatly boy
Airbnb has given people the chance to
sleep under the iconic glass pyramid at
the loof in putty like a giant slumber
party
yeah night at the Museum
where's my gum dumb-dumb there's too
much history in there for me to want to
see the bird dude isn't the Mona Lisa in
that yeah they say Mona Lisa is gonna be
your host
um gang scar very underwhelming yeah but
it's famous who gives a [ __ ] that's like
all famous like 700 Chinese people
standing in the front barrels like it
was terrible we went during a very high
tourist time yeah apparently it's not
like that all the time we also got lucky
we went to a time when the child still
poor
so there were no Chinese tourists so
yeah so there you're celebrating the
30th anniversary of the pyramid which
was built in 1980 yeah that's it oh
really it's around longer
I thought it was like in Storyful in the
80s that's don't put it before them
we're gonna put them on illicit before
no I mean I desecrated that it's just a
pyramid like the that's right it's like
one goes to the top and no one goes to
the bottle so the pyramid was designed
by Chinese American architect IM Pei Pei
that's nice you want this what I M Pei I
[ __ ] around the whole entire time I
saw the Mona Lisa and I just put like a
filter snapchat doggy filter on her
classic your culture does [ __ ] hi
Mildred I know I like to think that da
Vinci moved a little bit in his grave
it's like I was tying the past with the
future technology and you know it's a
very big art piece for me it's still my
[ __ ] snapshots damn you're like the
New Age Andy Warhol yeah I mean I don't
want to say it myself but yeah I know so
yeah so they're saying so they're doing
this competition here so you can apply
and the way you apply is you fill out
this Airbnb form and then it asks you if
you're able to travel between April 28th
and May 2nd and it asks you why you
would be Mona Lisa's perfect guest isn't
that one the French people smell the
worst that perfumes now no yeah but do
they use them the French people are
gonna [ __ ] in French people right oh
oh damn oh it's only one person sleeping
in there so everyone can see anything
I think it's multiple tents no no it's
one winner oh yeah what would you spend
the night there and then you get to hang
out with Mona Lisa in this area wait the
real one yeah like they exhumed and let
you be alone with that [ __ ] is a glass
case already you can [ __ ] a jerk your
dick off on it or something I don't even
move it into that room no cuz it's the
same I'm assuming it's the same place
where it's always
they just put all this [ __ ] around so it
feels like you're in a home or some [ __ ]
I see and then you get to hang out
around this statue Jordans called
David no David no it has a best alarm
was [ __ ] is that the girl
the armless Beach if you look over to
the left this is the ominous beach oh
man she's a divine goddess apparently oh
that's right somebody should have said
dude if you see a female statue chances
are it's either one of the goddesses or
Joan of Arc and that's it or more Mary
[Laughter]
[ __ ] it you get to relax and unwind
and Napoleon Thirds apartment which they
have at the how do you trust me not to
[ __ ] all this up see that's sick I'd
rather stay in there not the little not
the shitty trying alone alone okay you
just have an after-hours private coolest
gold-plated room that's in smug I'm
[ __ ] with that and see you like this
up a guitar summary now maybe somebody
but they're gonna they did mention
something about a concert acoustic
during an intimate acoustic concert
that's pretty cool it sounds like
somebody's gonna get murdered in there
like it looks like that it looks like
clue
yeah yeah murder mystery dinners oh I'm
down to one and then I couldn't make it
and I was like dang I really want to
know what that place I'm always afraid
to go to those murder mystery dinners
because it's highly evident who's really
stupid in there yeah I'm not gonna
understand the game at all dude that's
wrong on that I do escape rooms I don't
know what the [ __ ] going on
micki since we met her she's been saying
we got doing this because nikki is like
you know she is on the spectrum and
she's really good for sure yeah I'm fine
I'm just saying she's so [ __ ] go to
this [ __ ] she looks to the puzzle and
just immediately locks together in her
head and then I'm always like what the
[ __ ] is going on why I don't want to go
because everything else up until now is
assumptions that I'm dumb you guys can't
have actual proof yeah see exactly we've
seen you get hit by a surfboard fall
down some stairs bad luck it has nothing
to do with intelligence in a window come
on so she's done it - first of all
there's nothing to do with intelligence
every can do the fact that I'm [ __ ]
just about to die all the time yeah
alright and tell them I've seen a lot of
your injuries what do you tell you have
you we know each other now for almost
ten [ __ ] years the toilet seat yes I
shattered up yeah they made a porcelain
well this wasn't one of those moments
where it's like you're a fat person
that'd be crazy if it's like it's like
he's David's out on toilet seat once and
it turn into liquid like you've melted
it with your ass that's just usually a
junk but you made a real life yeah I've
actually broken a couple of you know at
the SAT classes yeah broken a couple
chairs in there too just by you sitting
on sitting on god you're so fat you turn
into a diamond
I remember my SAT feature was laughing
so hard he can teach oh Jesus cuz I
broke a chair there
twice how did it feel like sure you know
what it is i sat on it at an angle and
the one of the chairs legs gave it and
just went collapse did you say like
angle
what happened I dude [ __ ] hated my
guts because for a whole month before he
would so he had a class before and after
the class would leave me go on his
bathroom break but after he would leave
I would just turn the clock 30 minutes
faster and so we would leave about
between good I know it leave
he's like [ __ ] would just give
us material and then leave and then he
would come in and check in if people
needed help but I guess he does it so
often
you wouldn't know it's just time just
goes by fast he comes I was really quick
I liked it really was believed he's not
gonna complain how much is it is it just
the wind is efficient all I say would
you guys be down you were scared I'm
scared but I'd be down even if they gave
me this [ __ ] for free I'd say no thank
you
too much culture do you know sitting in
being in that pyramid thing people can
see you as [ __ ] not it they did mention
that presidents and celebrities have had
this exclusive opportunity now it's your
turn my Dame they do this [ __ ] for those
people I mean it cool for a blog there's
times when I shut down all the Disney
lines like Justin Bieber because explore
the whole part by himself in his posse
and stuff that's pretty serious to pay
for that [ __ ] yeah oh yeah [ __ ]
justice Beavis does it
well maybe not Bieber but you have to
pay for that kind of experience here
[ __ ] nobody
no dude even if you're Celebi like you
like to Brad like Brad Pitt or something
I still pay Michael Jackson shut down
them with the supermarkets we can go
shopping like a normal person that was a
great video yeah and they had his
friends like walk around pretending they
were customers maybe that's [ __ ] sad
bird in a cage
yeah it's so things like how much is
this and and then somebody be like it's
2 bucks and he's like oh wow as if the
price mattered no right now how much is
this it's four million dollars okay
putting in the car his estates worth
like 1.5 billion dollars Oh
Neverland or some [ __ ] the whole Michael
Jackson Este because of all the
royalties that they own or service
yeah state from state Essbase homie
states
oh really how do you product how do you
pronounce si si
yeah in your face let's end this video
now please what are your best life I
really even use estates insurance - of
course insurance when you ask me
somewhere where they live what do you
ask for Oh what's your address addresses
Masashi you guys are cornering this poor
man Lee Malone thank you dude Jesus no
this is like you guys we [ __ ] up is at
one time no this is like you got a kid
on the bus he's got speech impediment
you guys like say licorice again [ __ ]
freak thanks guys what's me one let's
talk about you defended David and
insulting at the same time drawing and
[ __ ] his one play with the song dick
let's pick on Gina
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]